[Music]
hey what's up behind the scenes before
to live mom's house podcast I'm making
sure all the drops are ready to go draw
smells like cotton balls colic are you
ready
blue bands behind the camera and we're
going to head out here in about 15-20
minutes or to live and yma show the
scenes this playlist by the way right
now I just together 61 songs
it's got like some fucking key dude I
found sounds of people submitted in 2012
all the way to ones that were submitted
this week we've had the best submissions
of music of any putts but every other
podcast somebody's are really
straight-up bangers dude is crazy I mean
this was like the podcast it created an
entire continent you know a few albums
or and this isn't all the songs this is
just a little deck here
just live it alone this meadow might be
slipping along this big huge metal
blasting out here area today what glass
let's go
football so this is the pre-show prep
and I like to go through it make sure
all the important things are here and
shitting check water champ stuff check I
guess I get everything ready I like to
make sure it's ready so that we have a
good show we're going to show you the
headers here brown and dental update
boners
dad boners very good stuff you say that
I've been cracking my eggs wrong oh my
god yeah you do it like a fuckin special
team skated Oh time is it brown come on
it's very important I know whoa whoa
whoa okay one two three four five don't
sound way better now I am his siblings
and letting his mother forbid Joey's
brother sister in America
you know what happens click yeah yeah
yeah yeah askin when you aerate your mom
my genes getting ready moaning all right
to the final model is very important
actually a sound check because we play
your clutch and you can't hear them in
the back it's this adapter so we've
learned over the years that you really
got to have loud stuff for those people
always back as though I'm important the
Irvine improv knows as well this is the
sign in the bathroom
meg Brown make sure to wash your hands
or little chunk 90 will find keeping the
motherfuckers out I hate hope if you
have to tag us I'm gonna make yellow
[Music]
bringing big balls water mixes is that
every scope reading that you re
recording this yeah Emmitt okay I can
call normally venesection
its partner to acclimatize are make sure
of it
you're having a drinking are they
bringing like gallon jug then fired up
are your jeans hi hi you must over even
if you resist that's way more scary it's
scarier than the fetish man no we know
this one is scary here because telling
you is scary this was much scarier on
accident look you've got high
[Music]
the first live podcast and Irvine was a
success has done amazing crowd thank you
for coming out
show number two is about to start and
the great Yoshio by Isis hey everyone
a buddy opposed to a French official in
silver special friends that from where
one from Germany and the one from
Baltimore from Baltimore yeah
Regina actually I can see that this is
my dear friend Steve Holmes the greatest
German porn star he's a freak of nature
there are many many visits sheet they
would inject stuff in their deck would
take medication she does not have to do
that in Barcelona ironic first of all he
was fucking three girls on stage trying
to sow immediate income you have a lot
of pressure to stand up try to slug
three girls on stage with a thousand
people looking at you so they're very
nice it just going to be a lot yes it'll
be looking just like old lady senior
citizen she doesn't look but you
purposely kind of luck right by her head
where does it happen Europe we're losing
our feet
potatoes cookies ice cream non key
though
hummus all very different parts all for
the show like a closed gas and all for
another public left Oh
what about Ryan Dogma it's sugar do
mature so we're putting out a birth show
everyone will be daddy gonna like that
about uh play like a fetish world today
they dress up like dog anyway track an
application is way too small no you guys
do the little stuff you got employed and
pull down harder
[Music]